but do you have a solution for how we
can lower gas prices yes do you have any
thoughts about it because right now we
have a four dollar national average some
parts of la it's like seven eight bucks
a gallon that i like
now that i think i think the solution to
gas prices you just raise la's prices
yeah only then only that's
dakota's price for two dollars and raise
la's to twenty eight dollars a gallon
yeah yeah i think it's a great idea
everybody wins
this is my this is my theory what's
gonna happen i think gas prices will go
up and they'll hit like [ __ ] nine ten
dollars and i think that would be like
them ukrainians are nazi's bro
like there's a big noxi faction in the
ukraine and we need to weed that [ __ ]
out and we need putin to do it because
he's the man for the job yeah that is my
suspicion
britney griner needs to come back
we need her for this year it's a big
year for the wwe a lot of things are
going on what team does she play for huh
what team does she play for uh
putin
i think she plays for team putin right
now and as long as we're on putin aside
we're going to lower these gas prices no
that's really what the war is about
right now the war it's it's like
you have all this support from the west
because the west hadn't been affected by
a lack of uh you know petroleum exports
from russia or natural gas too right so
it's like
the second we feel the effects we're
going to see how much support we have
for ukraine the people of ukrainian
relatives and stuff are always going to
ride for and support it but the average
dude that's in california that's in la
there's now paying eight dollars a
gallon nine dollars a gallon is he gonna
be posting the flag we're gonna see well
that's the other conspiracy angle where
oh there's a ton of environmentalists
like in the uk that got a lot of you
know stuff pipelines shut down and
basically the end result of it is
they're more dependent on russia yeah
and it's coming out
that russia's you know kind of funding a
lot of these organizations
you know there's there's a oh man i had
a tweet that i uh
[ __ ] screenshot or something like
that i don't know where it is but it was
like this what are like the top 10
facebook stories yeah the top 10
facebook stories before the war
and when russia had access or when the
russian like facebook farms were able to
you know put their energy into those
stories what was the exact thing because
basically facebook was banned in russia
or like that now russian like russian
facebookers aren't able to access their
accounts and so prior to the invasion
all like the top ten and for whatever
reason there's a few different things
happening with this but like for
whatever reason uh most of the time
leading up like the top ten were
typically right leaning on facebook it
was like benchmark
yeah
yeah yeah which kind of makes sense you
have like an older demographic on
facebook blah blah blah but then after
the invasion all the top things were
like occupy democrats like a bunch of
like left-leaning democratic facebook
retweet if you retweet of trump's orange
yeah basically like all on facebook and
so the thought is oh are there these
russian bots that are funding all this
right-wing information on and then they
switch facebook and they're just not
allowed to do it because they lost
access
but that doesn't explain ben shapiro and
talker really does it
i think it's important how would russia
be behind suggesting that russia is like
putting facebook ads and putting money
behind their content and trying to push
their content up on facebook they got
rid of russia today too the or like the
which i didn't realize the extent to
which they just like informed from
canada they have cbc right or in britain
they have the bbc which is paid for the
but you have to live i mean be a
resident to have a show there right
that's the whole thing russia russia has
this huge you know their national
broadcaster that has a bunch of
television shows in america
with american comedians
like there's a couple new york comics
that have tv shows on russia today that
oh rt yeah yeah yeah they just straight
up said they go
that's no longer like people are
tweeting like yeah my television
i think league camp yeah now
this is my suspicion now these are all
extreme
political
angles that they have right so whether
or not you agree with lee it is a very
extreme left take he's an extreme left
take yeah so if i was a foreign country
i would put money behind extreme right
takes ie ben shapiro tucker and extreme
left takes whatever one's convenient
and then you cause division because
division if you have the infighting then
we can't fight anywhere else and i think
that's what happened on facebook it's
not pushing any one ideology it's
pushing pushing extremists the extreme
ideologies polarization exactly and
that's what i and and that is the
strategy and i'm sure that's what china
is doing etc but so it doesn't surprise
me that lee camp his show is on russia
today and it doesn't surprise me that
they're putting money behind facebook
ads for shapiro
hypothetically speaking yeah well his is
a he was very you know it's a big
anti-war show which right now is a kind
of russia propaganda if you want to look
at it right 100
like war is bad it's like okay well what
are you working for putin yeah
yeah he was actually
he worked
today well dude i know them for putin
yeah they were buying tv shows and i'm
just like i was always like that's so
wild i have a tv show what network like
the russian government yeah it's like a
funny comedy show yeah yeah i remember
lee i remember him being in new york
he's a huge guy
yeah seems funny too but uh but yeah
that but that is weirdly enough like the
most and i know that he's uh actually
i'm not too familiar with politics but i
imagine like leaning a little bit more
socialists but like that is like the
most american capitalistic thing is like
take the bag from whoever gives it to
you yeah yeah
like it's
it's hard
to say oh russia's gonna give me money
so i can do my show okay boom i'm gonna
do it and it's always sometimes like a
bit of a [ __ ] you to who people who
wouldn't give you the bag anyway you go
all right well you could have gave me
money comedy central yeah
yeah absolutely now i'm fun in a war so
yeah
i think to that uh the the stories thing
apparently like a few days later they
were back to whatever they typically are
uh and it was just like a few day
windows that seemed like an anomaly and
for whatever reason that that's
disappointing or they figured out how to
use vpns in russia exactly yeah it's
tough to say i'm just
it's not on tv anymore i was talking
about specifically the story facebook
stories the articles
the top ten yeah the top tens and
whatever yeah i mean
however i don't know if if russia is
behind sowing division in the united
states of america however they sow that
division the united states of america
they will project that onto ukraine so
however we see ukraine through the lens
of russian media that will be the same
way that they divide america so it's not
surprising to me that all the
propagandas look at the nazis that are
in ukraine it's like yeah they've been
calling
americans nazis they know that works yes
they know how to piss they don't they
know how to rile us up yeah 100 right so
sure they know what they're doing so how
do we fix gas prices there anyway
i told you i mean there's easy ways but
people aren't going to like them
you know like all the pipelines they
wouldn't let happen and stuff like that
but the shoulder is probably the real
one but even more there's nuclear plants
you can just open back up
yeah well i don't know even musk came
out about that he's like yeah we have to
increase uh
[Applause]